in China it has been a grim and familiar
scene for much of December hospitals and
funeral homes overwhelmed in past weeks
as that country grapples with a surge of
covid-19 infections with cases topping
nearly 30 000 daily according to the
latest available data from The Who
the covet crisis in China prompting a
return of travel restrictions Canada
will now be requiring all travelers over
the age of two arriving from China Macau
or Hong Kong to show proof of a negative
covid-19 test tests must be taken two
days before their flight I guess it's a
good idea I believe in being safe when
you can Canada joins the U.S England and
Japan in opposing new travel
restrictions the move supported by BC's
Health Minister I think it's a prudent
step it's a great step to protect
Canadians protect Travelers and to
ensure we're safe there's a lot of
unknowns about the circumstance right
now and what's happening with the
pandemic in in the People's Republic of
China
Ottawa says the temporary measures are
in response to the surge of cases and a
lack of information from China including
genomic sequencing China has been
accused of not being transparent around
its covid situation and while no new
variants have been reported there are
growing concerns about possible
mutations not only do we have an
unprecedented level of infection
occurring in China right now which is a
real tragedy but we also have them
um agreeing to approving to have a drug
that causes a high rate of mutation in
the virus we do have some significant
information a lot of what they're
dealing with China are sub-variants of
what we know as the the Omicron variant
of concern so we do have some
information obviously we would like to
see more the new rules go into effect
January 5th at 1201 a.m eastern time and
will be in place for 30 days and then
reassessed Krista Dao Global News